c'est une nouvelle affaire de vente de
produits alimentaires impropres à la
consommation près de deux tonnes et
demie de viande commercialisés sous
forme de steak haché fortement
contaminés par la bactérie est ce qu'un
chat colis ont été vendus dans 110
magasins carrefour et monoprix au début
du mois les clientèles concernés n'ont
été avertis que dix jours après les
premiers constats de contamination
stéphanie perez jean michel la viande
contaminée a été débité dans cet
abattoir à coutances dans la manche
le 10 mars dernier près de deux tonnes
et demie de steaks hachés sont sortis
des chaînes de fabrication de la socopa
infectées par la bactérie escherichia
coli qui peut provoquer des gastro
entérites et des troubles rénaux
un incident de fabrication ponctuel
selon la socopa qui avance une hypothèse
lorsque il ya des fesses des faits c'est
ce que nous a dit ravet la bouse de
vache dtc d'haguenau ça salit le cuir de
l'animal
et lorsqu'on fait l'arrachage des cuites
il peut y avoir une projection le fait
cesse de ces animaux sur la carcasse
les lots de steaks hachés commercialisés
sous les marques monoprix et carrefour
ont été mises en vente dans 110 magasins
de la région parisienne de l'ouest et du
nord entre le 10 et le 18 mars mais les
clients ont été avertis que dix jours
après la contamination par ces
affichettes discrète au rayon boucherie
la viande avait donc déjà été achetés et
sûrement manger les enseignes justifie
ce délai plutôt long on ne peut pas
faire moins
c'est un délai d' analyse
incompressibles qu'on est obligé de
toute façon de respecter sinon ça ça ne
voudrait rien dire
monoprix et carrefour ont été contactés
aujourd'hui par une quarantaine de
personnes souffrent de diarrhées et de
nausées des symptômes pouvant être liés
à la bactérie
il reste maintenant à s'assurer que
quelle est la nature exacte de ces trous
mais est-ce que ça correspond
effectivement à vos symptômes qui
peuvent correspondre à un toxique est
une infection alimentaire de ce type
il va y avoir un lien bien sûr qui va
s'établir entre les données recueillies
par mlle prix et l'institut de veille
sanitaire les autorités sanitaires
relativise en indiquant que ce type
d'alerté fréquents et que le risque est
maîtrisé
deux numéros gratuits ont été mises en
place le 0 805 90 80 et le 0 800 7 173